Wir haben hier ja schon öfter darüber berichtet christa klaß 9 gilt als das neue wunderwerk zeug in der gentechnologie jetzt hat ein
chinesisches forschungsteam gezeigt
Dass die gen scherrer aber noch mehr kann als bislang angenommen ihr fazit
Sie eignet sich nicht nur für feinarbeiten sondern auch
Als krasse abrissbirne konkret konnte das forschungsteam mit ihrer hilfe in mozambique tatsächlich gezielt einzelne
Komplette chromosomen ausschalten wie das genau funktioniert hat und ob sich mit dieser methode schon bald auch
Krankheiten wie das down syndrom behandeln lassen könnten jetzt in klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Mit der so genannten küsst barkas neuen technologie kurz christa lassen sich ausgewählte
gene
einfügen
ausschalten oder auch umschreiben und zwar sehr einfach es funktioniert ganz
Simpel wie eine schere mit ihr kann die dna also das erbgut ziemlich effektiv verändert werden und bislang wurde indigenen schere
tatsächlich nur dafür eingesetzt erbgut
zu korrigieren einzelne gene auszuschalten oder neue erbgut stücke einzufügen wir haben ja schon öfter darüber berichtet doch jetzt hat ein
forschungsteam der peking university auf ein neues eindrucksvoll gezeigt dass diese technologie viele bereiche der wissenschaft der medizin
Und ja vielleicht sogar die welt wie wir sie kennen
revolutionieren könnte in ihrem versuch haben die chinesen nämlich gezeigt dass das gen werkzeug auch anders kann statt der gewohnten
Feinarbeit gab es jetzt ein regelrechtes gemetzel und ja es
Grenzt schon an eine sensation denn dem forschungsteam ist es gelungen ein komplettes chromosomen. Im wahrsten sinne des wortes zu pulverisieren
Zurück zu ihrem experiment das sie an mäusen durchgeführt
hatten in 40 prozent in denen die gene aktiv wurde gelang es das y-chromosom
der nervenzellen von mäusen föten im mutterleib zu eliminieren
dazu einer der beteiligten forscher koyang die christopher kas 9
vermittelte zielgerichtete chromosomen eliminierung bietet einen neuen ansatz um eine therapeutische
strategie für android die
erkrankungen mit zusätzlichen chromosomen zu entwickeln damit gemeint sind krankheiten wie das klinefelter syndrom bei dem ein
zusätzliches x-chromosomen vorlegt das sogenannte xy
y syndrom oder eben das relativ weit vorn
down syndrom weltweit
Haben etwa fünf millionen menschen diese erkrankung alle drei minuten kommt ein baby mit down syndrom zur welt ihr habt es vielleicht, mal
im biologieunterricht mitbekommen beim down syndrom liegt das chromosom 21
drei statt zwei mal vor in der medizinischen fachsprache bezeichnet man das eben als
analogie also eine genmutation bei der zusätzlich zum üblichen
Chromosomensatz weitere chromosomen vorhanden sind ich hoffe ich habe es richtig ausgesprochen die medizin ist mittlerweile soweit dass ab der neunten schwangerschaftswoche
Festzustellen dann kann die schwangerschaft abgebrochen werden ja bislang gibt es keine möglichkeit die erkrankung noch
mutterleib zu behandeln doch das experiment aus china macht tatsächlich hoffnung dass dies demnächst möglich sein könnte vielleicht sogar
während der schwangerschaft division mit hilfe einer gentherapie
überzählige chromosomen gezielt entfernt dieses ergebnis ist also tatsächlich ein absoluter hinhörer und vielleicht sogar der anfang eines neuen
zeitalters
doch
Realistisch gesehen ist diese methodik noch nicht wirklich bereit für die praxis denn es gibt zu viele schnitte an stellen die so ganz und gar
Nicht gewollt sind nicht vorstellbar was passieren würde wenn in einem lebenden organismus die falschen
chromosomen zerstört würden zudem ist die
Effizienz mit einer erfolgsquote von 40 prozent bisher noch viel zu gering wenn ihr kein video zu diesem thema und auch zu allen anderen themen
Verpassen wollt dann drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge vergesst nicht den
Genau auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr auch immer über neue videos informiert hier geht es weiter mit dafür unbedingt draufklicken doktor frankenstein
Wird realität da geht es um die gene von alten mammuts sehr spannendes thema ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran